bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france affrontements avec
les forces de l'ordre
un mort plusieurs blessés les
arrestations qualifiés d'arbitraires
comment vous voyez la suite des
événements en biélorussie la suite est
un champ politique et je suis de
regarder je suis un nazi les élections
en france avec une jeune femme serge
july et après-vente un lâche qui a fait
de la traduction dans différentes ong
qui n'a jamais été particulièrement
médiatisée qu'était partie d'aucun parti
politique qui n'a aucune expérience
politique qui n'a aucune caméra cognitif
qui se présentent à des élections dans
ciels il était plutôt réellement
ménagers je suis une grande surprise
en revanche la façon dont ça tourne
autour de cette défaite
particulièrement attendu est en fait
complètement logique et elle a beaucoup
plus surprenante puisque atteint l'union
européenne et des états unis à la
reconnaître
cela nous rappelle comme d'ailleurs là
parfaitement dit la représentation d'un
rocher est venu sa retraite ça rappelle
forcément le scénario guen je ne suis
pas sûr que ça ait tranché alors avec
les romantiques mais en attendant il ya
quand même des manifestants qui
contestent la réélection
du président pour un sixième mandat en
général ça c'est normal
le problème c'est que cette habitude
maintenant descendre dans la rue moment
où je vais conserver n'a pas été dans
l'armée
quand on regarde les vidéos ce ne sont
pas des masses deuxième chose il ya
quand même des choses assez prenant par
exemple que la police biélorusse est
arrêté ou interpellé et arrêté un homme
récemment que l'on raté l'essai des
british et qui s'est retrouvé avec des
huiles de leurs chimiques qu'ils étaient
en train de distribuer aux mêmes raisons
donc la question que s'est posée quelle
est la part des gens qui réellement en
ont marre d'agen boé sortant et ceux qui
sortent parce que quelque chose qu'il
faut dire que c'était super on parle
quand même de faire mille arrestations
jugées arbitraires
il ya quand même des forces de sécurité
qui interviennent de façon musclée
il ya on déplore un mort un blessé il d
une répression dans la rue il ya une
répression dans la rue selon vous est ce
fameux manifeste pour pacifier les
médias occidentaux schéma gorge
l'odeur dans la main il apparut ciel
[Musique]
donc si vous voulez je pense qu'il faut
quand même feront pas mal de recul et
éviter de ressortir les armes mais
l'argument un peu d'un scénario à la cnm
des gens qui manifestants contre les
mauvaises fort d'abord parce que a
priori est assez bonne et je suis pas en
état à l'identique il n'est pas globale
or c'était principalement reprocher le
cash en cours c'était pas à bord dickie
chose nouvelle fois et c'est ça le
problème
principal de la situation de l'emploi
des jeunes avec le peuple russe est prêt
pour renverser les jo de vancouver
alors là l'union européenne qui prévoit
une réunion de ses ministres des
affaires étrangères vendredi que peut-on
attendre justement de cette réunion par
ailleurs la position de moscou vis-à-vis
de la biélorussie alors en ce qui
concerne l'union européenne vision
avancé l'idée de prendre des sanctions
j'avais c'était assez commun lorsque la
personne des champions la question de
savoir quelle est l'ampleur réelle
diversification au delà furieux de tout
discours extrêmement fanatiques de parts
et d'autres
parce que le problème c'est que ces
accusations pour l'instant le chantier
n'ont pas démenti fait ça ce serait pas
intéressant donc je suis avec les deux
gammes et de rationaliser deuxième chose
en ce qui concerne l'attitude de la
russie et rita c'est surprenant je
dirais que l'on est vue par certains
médias russes le média systémique
on reprend des informations de sources
sont diffusés partie d'août par exemple
l'avion d'une cachette
bush s'était envolé le 9 avant qu'il
avait fui le pays avant même les
résultats
on a vu aussi des informations sur dans
laquelle il reconnaît aussi les
déclarations d'une idée du beau monde y
vient disons que l'opposante avait été
interpellé de la russie quelques
pêcheurs prenantes
je comprends consisté en russie aussi
des les points de vue six nations
dalé ces dernières venaient y est certes
un avant goût de ce cycle de la tête et
il sait répondre intéressant de penser
vraiment quelque chose mais si à présent
très fat et gic puisque malheureusement
aujourd'hui le paysage politique en
général
farid que ce soit entériné ce choix aux
antilles dans général il est difficile
et qu'il y ait des alternatives
politiques s'occupent sur un problème d'
alternative idéologique soit vous avez
des unités qui est pas le cas d et e
vous allez chez nous en rage avec le
même temps et on a vu ce qui se passait
au pouvoir mais les temps de réflexion à
avoir
merci à vous car éméché golovkov pour
cette analyse merci à vous